well now use that that equation we just
derived to to go back and solve a or at
least address that same problem we were
doing before so let's write that
equation down again so actually let's
write the problem down let's say I have
the cliff again and so my initial
distance is zero but it goes down five
hundred meters I'm not going to redraw
the cliff because it takes a lot of
space up on my my limited chalkboard so
we know that the change in distance
change in distance is equal to minus 500
meters and I'm going to still use the
example where I don't just drop the ball
or the penny or whatever I'm throwing
off the cliff I actually throw it
straight up so it's going to go up and
slow down from gravity and then you know
go to zero velocity then start
decelerating downwards or you can even
say decelerating in the other direction
but the initial velocity VI is equal to
let's say 30 meters per second and of
course we know that the acceleration is
equal to minus ten meters per second
squared because we're acceleration
gravity is always pulling downwards or
towards the center of our planet if we
wanted to figure out the final velocity
we could have just used the formula we
did this in the last video VF squared is
equal to VI squared plus two ad but now
what I want to do is see if we I'm going
to use the the formula we learned in the
very last video to figure out how long
does it take to get to the bottom of to
hit the ground so let's use that formula
we that we derived and I'll write in a
different color we derived that the
change in distance change in distance is
equal to the initial velocity times time
plus acceleration times squared over two
that's initial velocity so the change in
distance is minus 500 minus 500 is equal
to the initial velocity well that's
positive going upwards 30 meters per
second 30 T I'm not going to write the
unit's right now because it'll just make
things I'll run out of space but you can
redo it with the units and see that the
unit's do work out when you square time
you have to square the time units
although we're solving for time plus
acceleration plus acceleration
acceleration is minus ten we're going to
divide it by two right so it's minus
five minus 5t squared so we have minus
500 is equal to 30 T and we could you
know plus minus 5t squared we just say
minus 5t squared to get rid of this plus
so at first you're saying well Sal these
there's t that's you know T to the first
to the second how do I solve this and
and hopefully you've taken algebra 2 or
Algebra one in some places and you know
you remember how to solve this otherwise
you're about to learn the quadratic
equation although I recommend you go
back and you learn about factoring in
the quadratic equation which there are
videos on that I've put on on YouTube so
I hope you watch those first if you
don't remember but we can do a list but
let's put these two right terms on the
left hand side and then we'll use a
quadratic equation to solve it sound
think this is easy to factor so we get 5
T squared minus 30 t minus 500 is equal
to zero I just took these terms and put
them on the left side and we could
divide both sides by 5 just to I don't
know just to simplify things so we get T
squared minus 6t minus 100 is equal to 0
right and I could do that because I 0
divided by 5 is just 5 so it just
cleaned it up a little bit so let's use
a quadratic equation and for those of us
who need a refresher I'll write it down
so the roots of any quadratic and in
this case you know it's T we're solving
for T will equal negative B plus or
minus the square root of b squared minus
4ac over 2a where a is the coefficient
on this term B is the coefficient on
this term negative 6 and C is the
constant so minus 100 so let's just
solve so we get T is equal to negative B
so negative this term well this term is
negative 6 so if we make it a negative
it becomes plus 6 so becomes 6 plus or
minus the square root
of B squared so it's minus 6 squared 36
minus 4 minus 4 times a the coefficient
on a is here that's just 1 times 1 for
AC C is a constant term minus 100 minus
4 times 1 times minus 100 times minus
100 all of that over 2a well a is 1
again so all of that over 2 that just
equals 6 plus or minus the square root
this is minus 4 times minus 100 so these
become pluses so it becomes 36 plus 400
right so 6 plus or minus 436 divided by
2 and this is not a clean number and if
you type it into your calculator it's
something on the order of about 20 20.9
we can just say approximately 21 you
might want to get the exact number if
you were actually doing this on a test
or trying to send something to Mars but
for our purposes I think you'll get the
point so I'll say it approximately now
because we're going to be a little off
but just have clean numbers this is
approximately 21 it's a little it's like
20 point 9 we'll say 6 plus or minus now
let me just write twenty point nine
twenty point nine over two so T is
approximately six so let me ask you a
question if I do if I do so let's do if
I do six minus twenty point nine what do
I get I get a negative number and does a
negative time make sense
no it does not that means that somehow
in the in the past well I don't want to
get philosophical the negative time in
this context will not make sense so
really we can just stick to the plus
right because six minus 20 is negative
so six will just there's only one time
that solves this in a meaningful way so
time is approximately equal to six plus
twenty point nine so that's twenty six
point nine over 2 and that equals what
thirteen point four five
13 0.45 and seconds time is equal to
that's interesting I think if you
remember way back may 4 or 5 videos ago
when we first did this problem we just
dropped we just dropped the penny
straight from from the height and I've
actually in that problem I gave you the
time I said it took 10 seconds to hit
the ground and we worked backwards to
figure out that the cliff was 500 meters
high now so if you if it you're at the
top of a 500 meter cliff or building and
you drop something that has no air
resistance like a penny that has very
little air resistance it would take 10
seconds to reach the ground assuming you
know all of our assumptions about
gravity whatever but if you were to
throw the penny straight up you know off
the edge of the cliff at 30 meters per
second right here it's going to take
13.5 roughly 13 and a half seconds to
reach the ground so it takes a little
bit longer and that that should make
sense because actually let me I have
time to draw a little picture in the
first case Oh me in the first case I
just took the penny and it's motion just
went straight down in the second case I
took the penny it first went up and then
it went down right so it had all the
time when it went up and then it had it
kind of went down a longer distance so
it makes sense this time is 10 10
seconds well this time was thirteen
point four five seconds so you can kind
of say that it took it took well you
actually can't say that well you well
yeah I don't want to I don't get too
involved but hopefully this makes sense
to you if you've got a smaller number
here you should you would have gone and
checked your work because why would it
take less time when I throw the the
object straight up
so hopefully that that gave you a little
bit of more intuition and you really do
have all in your arsenal now all of the
equations and hopefully the intuition
you need to to solve basic projectile
problems I'll now do a couple of more
videos where I just do a bunch of
problems just to really really drive the
point home
and then I'll expand these problems to
two to demit two dimensions and angles
and and before we get there you might
want to refresh your trigonometry I'll
see you soon